the word sorry isn't enough for
survivors and those bereaved
spread right across ireland the secrets
of 18 institutions concealed the deaths
of an estimated 9 000 babies and young
children
hidden mass graves one in the corner
here by a playground
this is tune county galway it was a home
run by
nuns where nearly 800 babies were buried
in and around a disused sewage tank
tumor nine more mother and baby homes
run by the catholic church
took in young unmarried mothers there
were eight
other institutions the state was
supposed to be paying for care
yet the women lived like prisoners most
survivors and bereave relatives believe
the reports findings and government
action
is too little too late it seems that our
worst fears have been realized
they are going to trivialize the major
overarching topics that relate to the
growth human rights abuses in those
homes
birth outside marriage had been treated
not only as a sin
but a crime in a country where a
staunchly conservative catholic
church held considerable sway
the penalty for young women was
servitude often
sexual abuse forced labor and loss of
their babies
thousands of infants died through
neglect cruelty and
other abuses or they were sold by nuns
in what they considered to be adoption
this was my mother bridges and this was
my father with him
anna corrigan's mother bridget dolan was
in tune
a book has been written about her she
lost one son who died of neglect
another was taken away by the nuns never
to be seen or heard of again
it's the culmination of a lot of years
of waiting and
research she says it was a series of
government cover-ups and deliberate
delays and denials
our mantra was delayed and i till we all
go away and die
my parents are gone my brothers are
missing
dead not dead my aunt is stumped in a
pit
in la grey and i'm the voice
anna's voice has been a loud one in
calling for justice and closure
she says the report falls short of both
no one has been brought to justice
yet it went on for 76 years ending in
1998.
the report says the church and state
were partly responsible
but they provided refuge the women
weren't forced into the homes according
to the report
it says the fathers of their children
and their families provided
no refuge that assertion has been met
with outrage
what happened has often been termed the
irish mother and babies scandal
many may feel that's an understatement
and the word
atrocities may prove more accurate
andrew simmons al jazeera